Mariya Rosemere 'va is fearless the 67
year old may have trouble walking but
she still been taken to the streets of
Moscow with a relative konstantin every
weekend for nearly two months now even
after the russian police responded with
mass arrests when candidates are
borrowed from elections and basic
democratic rights are violated she says
you have to protest even if I'm half
dead or have to crawl
I'll take part in every protest that can
prevent the destruction of my country
and my people because that's what I'm
seeing here and the propaganda on
television won't stop me which is not
demonstrating Maria spends her days
lying down the former teacher has
rheumatism and is an almost constant
pain
she stopped watching the state TV
channels years ago she says because it's
all lies she prefers critical online
media and opposition bloggers like
politician Alexei Navalny Maria grew up
in a politically active family in the
Soviet Union and had hoped a very
different system would replace it but
she says the current situation in Russia
is just as repressive as the former
regime the government can do whatever it
wants with whomever at once
it can hit anyone at any time they can
take away your property or even your
freedom it can happen to anyone at all
or even to those loyal to the government
the Picasso's are in danger of losing
custody of their youngest son they've
been accused of taking him along to
demonstrations many Russians are shocked
that the government would take such
extreme measures
we love our children very much and we
hope that this case doesn't tear our
family apart over a dozen protesters
have been taken to court for allegedly
inciting mass uprisings at protests in
recent weeks observers say the state is
using the trials as a show of strength
many of these trials give you the
impression they're not prosecuting with
the aim of reaching a verdict they're
prosecuting just so they can arrest
search and interrogate people to
intimidate them the rest doesn't matter
Russian President Vladimir Putin defends
the harsh methods of police and the
courts with comparisons to France and
the yellow vest demonstrations we all
know how things went with the yellow
vests during these demonstrations in
France by our estimates 11 people lost
their lives we don't want anything like
that to happen in the Russian capital
and we'll make every effort to ensure
our domestic situation remains strictly
within the framework of the law but
Maria rasma reverse says the protests
were all held within the framework of
the law she always greets the police and
special forces at the demonstrations
with a smile because she says the
Russian people must be united not
divided she's determined to keep
fighting for basic democratic rights at
all costs it's my duty I'd feel like a
criminal like a sinner if I didn't take
to the streets now they can even load
wheelchairs into police cars I don't
think I'd survive if I got arrested
but the risk is justified Maria as
marathas signs says hold violators at
the Constitution accountable
whenever rights are flatted in Russia
she'd like to see ever more people put
their fears aside to take the streets
and protest just like her